je vous le dis il ya un grand tournoi de
tennis qui va se jouer en france bah oui
à partir du bassin s'il vous plaît on ne
peut plus là je vais aller happer
brigitte patron alors il ya un grand
tour diniz qui va se jouer là dès ce
week end
c'est un tournoi de tennis où il y aura
des très grandes stars de tennis s'est
organisée par patrick moratoglou qui est
l'entraîneur de serena williams entre
autres à il a eu une vie un peu spécial
ça s'appelle ultimate tennis showdown il
veut dire ultimate tennis chaude a géré
mini championnat un peu différent de ce
qui se passe à cuba voilà non mais bon
voilà la tp qu'on appelle l' association
des tennismen professionnels dits les
plus grands joueurs du monde vont
s'affronter tour à toi avant de se
qualifier pour la phase finale
50 matchs seront disputés avec 5 pas de
jouer tous les samedis les dimanches et
côté diffusion d'une chaîne télé a été
créé pour 9 euros 99 par mois et je vois
les joueurs
moi je voulais dire ouais sites s'y
passe qu'est ce qui s'passe berrettini
l'italien matteo je connais bien david
goffin un pote de belgique va pessiot et
revérifié phoenix roger alias simon le
numéro 20 mondial canadien benoit paire
un ami ami richard gasquet au nahd
lucas pouille un animal expo pirine et
dustin brown un allemand accuse alors
moi ce que je propose c'est qu'on les
appelle tout de suite on facetime qui
s'appelle patrick moratoglou c'est
l'entraîneur de serena williams est
pardonné aux partenaires à quoi je suis
pas dedans
il ya un tournoi il se passe que c'est
en france et à côté de chez moi
voilà je vous le dis ça sophia antipolis
à coude et nice sophia antipolis est une
ville à part entière richard gere le
joueur s'est pas mise d'accord c'est
biot
il ya biot sophia antipolis et voilà
voilà
à bas les voilà patrick et benoît
savamment benoît d'amour ouais pleine
face voilà j'ai fait une petite voiture
pour toi mais jamais wen a été fou quoi
j'ai les fous je laisse pousser tu me
regardes plus toi oh les mecs b civique
on le sait moins c'est tellement bon
réelles et chéri vous êtes amoureux tout
doullens exactement vous êtes très sains
vous êtes un petit peu chez moi vous
êtes sur la terrasse un falloir payer
les bacs à sel et chérif bah oui battant
ça me fait plaisir
gaël gigal hier benoît il est très très
chaud il m'a dit lui et moi au paddle on
est imbattable
ida temps installé mais quand vous
voulez on est tous aux médias que trois
capteurs cyril en tâtant cette fois ci
tu parles d'un match de foot tu es là
bas ce week-end
et bien sûr je suis là-bas suis sûr là
il ya eu des mères je viens pour toi je
me régale
amel moi ce talent que la nature est
aussi là mais je viens sous quatre jours
est une tannée trois ténors et patrick
dix mois patrick tu vas t'on à deux ou
fla et il ya tout le monde paye à benoît
paire et assis dessus passe hélas goffin
et à nouaillé où c'est une fan ou quoi m
unal j'espère qu'il vient regarder ma
passion
[Applaudissements]
j'ai regardé comme un homme magnifique
soirée les télés sécu c'est l'entraîneur
de serena williams à la gagne et coiffe
un grand chelem
si on te remets tes les mois en matinée
moi tu vois pas le patrice deniau matrix
est honteux bravo pourquoi mais que je
suis maman attend toujours le bienvenu
ici tu sais moi je suis bien mieux mais
bon sang que cyril depuis tout à l'heure
il a envie de jouer ils aimeraient quand
la vie dis-moi frère tu croyais pas dire
là bas pour servir d diabolo fraise
battant haut et on est on est regardés
on a faim record d'audience hier les
gens nous regardent les gens se disent
quoi et vous à dire quoi hanouna c'est
quoi c'est fini il y vit dans le passé
avec les secteurs même niveau que tous
les ans alors je vais vous dire quelque
chose et benoît paire qu'un immense
joueur ouais bah vous dire pour lui je
suis au même niveau que bad au même
niveau que tous les joueurs combien
densité oui ils sont dans le tournoi oui
franchement élus au même niveau
il mérite il a sa place ici série le mas
des tuiles annuler c'est oublier ça
c'est moi qui dois de l'oseille matin
patrick maugère est cuite nous le
tournoi parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui
nous qui nous regardent et qui ont envie
de vous suivre
en fait l'idée c'est de faire du tennis
mais de d'explorer un nouveau format
format beaucoup plus moderne plus
dynamique plus court avec beaucoup plus
d'interaction avec le public avec qui
sera pas sur place mais qui reviendra à
la télé il est celle interagir avec eux
et de faire intervenir aussi d'autres
personnes que les joueurs à savoir les
coaches bien sûr et pourquoi pas les
entourages
on était vachement inspiré de tout ce
qui fonctionne en télé notamment ce type
d'émission qui est qu'ils sont les des
choses qui plaisent aux gens et on s'est
dit que le tennis en fait c'était un
spectacle qui était très très lent et
pas raison qui est fait dans lequel les
joueurs s'exprimer pas assez alors il ya
un benoît heureusement qu'il ya des
bonnes on a encore bien sûr non mais je
suis très seule quand il ya de benoît il
ya des gaels c'est aussi parce que je
suis
les ressent sur le court ah ouais mais
les les hausses pas la plupart d'entre
eux ils osent pas tellement montrer
leurs émotions à ce code de conduite est
quand même très rigide il faut être un
peu fou comme commente yama rade pour
poser le brave et mai mais j'ai envie
que les joueurs s'exprimer j'ai envie
qu'on les connaisse mieux et j'ai envie
que il fasse un peu vibrer les gens en
montrant leurs toutous leur sentiment
sur le court je sais que c'est un
concept qui est vraiment complètement
novateur qui va coacher tournoi qui
plaira côté benoît mois l'école c'est
compliqué mais toi si tu veux tu peux
venir me coacher sur est non mais au
fond 0 laisse moi te coûte j'ai fais moi
plaisir samedi dimanche si tu veux tu es
mon kot non mais charrie pas du tout là
tu sais que je pense que là je serai là
je charrie pas du tout là benoît et même
d'en démissionner samedi dimanche
mais mon coach frère moi je moi je vais
te coach et moi patrick dans la tête du
challenge je suis un des plus forts
actuellement tu le sais mais clairement
si c'est gênant du le nom c'est pas les
toucher non c'est bon tu mets toi
piloselle touareg et non dans la dans la
tête tu très fort arrêter les mecs c'est
un coach comme moi qui donne les dires
de garde s'est référée qu'est ce que
vous voulez dire ya benoît pour le
pauvre il sait très bien j'ai les
mauvezinois il a le talent moi c'est le
cerveau ça suffit deux autres séries
dont la panne mais non j'ai le mental
frère mais toi tu est attitude c'est
intelligent mais tu t'énerves c'est
comme moi comme moi dans les émissions
samedi démangé tu es là bon je suis là
elles sont rien je suis là patrick tu
veux te fait des gros bisous mon chéri
et on va suivre ça et franchement t il
sur ut est ce live ouais exactement
on va regarder les remercier mon patrick
et merci benoît je suis avec vous ce
week-end
je vous fais je fais des bisous qui dit
à tout le monde ça allait on t'embrasse
mon frère et vous êtes vers les deux
sara lee
bravo pour la coupe à patrick aussi ça
bouge pas oui ça bouge pas toi tu bouges
pat était magnifique et dia serena
williams je vais
apprendre en simple on est en droit vous
avez c'est vrai que vous avez un mental
de tueur redite les noms les noms des
mecs qui vont être la loire redire s'y
passe voilà encore encore plus les
timides avant en fin de droits père
richard gasquet comme lucas pouille
c'est là que vous avez un mental de cas
des mecs ont fait roland garros et vous
vous étonnez qui vous appelle vous avez
un mental d'acier ou vous avez un melon
et nexans avait la confiance on vient
leur rappeler que vous avez battu
djokovic inquiété des balles j'ai quand
même l'argent qui vous prennent pour un
bouffon c'est grave
alors elle est à son aise face on ne
vous inquiétez pas là pas encore signé
dans les prochaines années mais sont
très forts parce que vous les avez
appelé en commençant l'accord sur dix
ans je veux jouer comment ça se fait que
je joue pas pour elle finissait la
conversation
tu seras ainsi entraîneur ouais ouais
c'est vrai moi je vous avais mon
caractère je trouve je suis surpris
parce que vous aimez retraite de
remplaçant il vous et vous entrez chez
de remplaçant et maintenant que vous
l'avez forcer la main avant l'avis du
public
s'il vous plaît laissez-moi public un
nom sinon vous êtes alors vous et ont
été réalistes
non mais moi je voulais savoir si vous
alliez liés mais maintenant je suis allé
à vous les liens qu elle venir avec moi
je pense oui je veux tu veux dire moi je
veux dernière je prends très bons avec
moi tu vas me dire tu vois si je vais
venir à les voilà bah vous venez vous
j'aimerais bien passé il ya des joueurs
de ouf
mais bien sûr ben si c'est un mot c'est
un peu de tv réalité ces noms et photos
je viens aussi à moi je veux voir et
revoir jouer la phase i avec plaisir tu
t'es turquie sont foutus de ma gueule ou
pas un trouve qu'ils se sont foutus de
ma gueule
non non ils sont rejoints en route un
peu fou tu de ta gueule mais tu
non plus que ce qu'on a pu bien plus
révolutionnaire ici c'est que moratoglou
et permet au genre d'insulté donc vous
comme sur le terrain vous pouvez dire
espèce de connard tu es complètement nu
usd sa peau quant aux vêtements pour
vous selon lui la famille diallo
[Rires]
familiale bon ben alors les joueurs
c'est pour faire du push ce week-end ce
débat c'est bus qui se prennent pour des
taux encore là c'est dur et c'est encore
elle égrène pour la salle a mais je leur
mets d'état né à tout cela la cité bois
à voir c'est quoi ça transpire votre
passion pour le tennis et on est
vraiment pour vous allez va transpirer
c'est votre passion pour le pôle emploi